you know there's been so many revivals
of like you know buffy or whatever
they're doing going back and doing like
six episodes of party down and this and
that yeah uh reno 9-1-1 do you think if
they ever asked you to do a chuck like
kind of like a little five-episode thing
or something you'd consider it
well they're talking to you about it
you're smiling so
so i've been trying to make a chuck
movie
since before we even finished the show
like i i i was always like you know for
almost no money budget and no time we
were basically making a mini action
movie every week anyway right and so if
you had like a little more budget and a
little more time we could make i think
some really killer little truck movies
you know and put them online whatever
the heck i've been literally trying to
do this since 2012
wow
and uh
dude i feel like the time is is not
it's nigh yeah i i've had some very
good promising conversations with
uh producers well with with the creators
josh schwartz and chris fedak and we had
a really lovely get together and catch
up and you know
i a few well during the pandemic we did
we did a chuck reunion um
zoom you know uh a deal and um
it was so great i mean i think it was a
great reminder for everybody like just
how special and magical our little
family was and and and everyone was just
like right back into it it was it was
really great and uh and i think josh and
and chris you know and they've built
entire empires for themselves now and it
just and the time is i think is good so
hopefully i don't know we'll see i for
all the chuck fans who are listening to
this right now this is not well maybe
i'll i don't know i don't know this is
an official announcement yeah i don't
know if this is an official announcement
or not but i will tell you that for all
of you have been patient thank you for
your patience i have not stopped trying
and i will not stop trying i've joked
that i will you know even if i'm a
geriatric chuck we're going to do it one
day
but um but yeah man i think i think
we're close to making something happen
which i'm super excited about and and i
think it works perfect because now you
know like it's a warner brothers show
it's you know it's owned by warner
brothers and um
you know and i think that uh
you know with all the streamers now and
you know
hbo max i mean you know like that
we could easily just start making some
movies and putting them there and just i
want to roll yeah i want some role in
that oh we'll work on that we'll work on
that
you